Ryan Reynolds has always been a fun-loving,
good-looking guy.
But if you compare his early days in Hollywood
to his more recent outing as everyone's favorite
foulmouthed superhero, you might notice that
he hasn't always had the beefed-up physique
that looks so good in red spandex.
How did this former child actor turn his body
from lean to mean?
Be warned: there aren't any tricks — just
time, energy, and dedication.
It all began with Blade
Reynolds' big comic book movie breakthrough
came over a decade ago, when he played vampire
hunter Hannibal King in the 2004 film Blade:
Trinity.
"The trainer before we started the film wanted
to pack on about ten pounds on me and muscle
up"
In the three months before filming began,
Reynolds was whipped into good enough shape
to occupy space in a superhero flick, if not
headline one himself.
The secret?
Long workouts, heavy weights, and zero cardio
— because believe it or not, before he packed
on the muscle to play this role, Ryan Reynolds
was kind of a noodle.
Every day is a gym day
Wanna be a superhero?
Prepare not to slack off… ever.
"Mmmmmaximum effort!"
Some of the routines Reynolds has to follow
border on the sadistic.
For instance, when he first had to bulk up
for Green Lantern, the actor worked out seven
days a week, 90 minutes a day, and never did
the same workout twice — for six straight
months.
Even his rest days just involved a less intense
type of exercise, like Pilates.
But don't worry; for those of us who aren't
putting our abs on display for an audience
of millions, 20 minutes of moderate exercise
daily and three gym sessions per week will
be more than adequate to keep you fit.
He eats all of the food
When it comes to playing Deadpool, the first
time Reynolds suited up wasn't in his own
stand-alone film — it was in 2009's X-Men
Origins: Wolverine, a regrettable outing that
would eventually become the butt of Deadpool's
best marketing jokes.
"But, the movie, that was a career low for
me, you understand."
But back then, the actor wasn't going to pass
up the chance to bring Wade Wilson to life
onscreen, and he had to bulk up fast — which
meant consuming enormous amounts of food.
Reynolds said that he had to eat live children
in order to put on so much muscle in so little
time — but he was kidding, of course.
Probably.
He focuses on nutrition
The theme of any good superhero diet?
Protein, protein, and protein — and if you're
Ryan Reynolds, plenty of carbs, too.
The actor says, "I really don't believe in
that no-carb stuff.
It's probably not good for you — and it
makes you pretty cranky."
No amount of exercise will make up for poor
nutrition.
Eating the right foods in the right amounts
— and at the right times, if you're being
really intense about it — is key to building
a physique like this one.
That said, even superheroes get the occasional
cheat day to indulge in some not-so-healthy
foods like...
"It's a chimichanga"
But actually, Reynolds prefers to gorge on
pizza when he doesn't have to look ripped
onscreen.
He keeps it tight
Ryan Reynolds might shed some muscle or change
up his workout between superhero flicks, but
he's basically been in battle-ready shape
for the past fifteen years — which makes
it easy to ramp things back up when he needs
to slide into a spandex suit.
According to his longtime trainer Bobby Strom,
"For [action films] he was 200 pounds and
8 percent body fat.
For rom-coms, he's about 180 and 11 percent
body fat."
But even then, Reynolds is a gym regular;
says Strom, "When he does a comedy, he probably
goes to the gym to do cable work every other
day."
He sets challenging goals
Reynolds has said that getting in shape for
movie roles left him astonished at what could
be achieved with a solid workout regimen — and
now, he keeps himself motivated by giving
himself new goals to strive for.
Of course, for someone as fit as Reynolds,
those goals have to be pretty intense.
Among the items already crossed off his bucket
list is running the New York City marathon
in under four hours.
Next up?
He wants to climb Machu Picchu.
He has fun with it
Ultimately, Ryan Reynolds approaches fitness
the same way he approaches… well, everything:
by not taking himself too seriously.
Sometimes that means finding motivation in
unusual places — like a friendly rivalry
with his Deadpool 2 co-star Josh Brolin, who
got even more muscled up than Reynolds to
play the character Cable.
But the actor also knows his limits, and isn't
afraid to point out when another superhero
star has surpassed him in physical achievement.
When asked how his own regimen stacked up
against Hugh Jackman's, who would wake up
at two o'clock in the morning in order to
eat enough to fuel his Wolverine workouts,
Reynolds said, "Hugh Jackman has a dedication
to his craft that I'm afraid I don't share.
If I'm up at 2 in the morning, it's because
something has gone terribly wrong."
That laid-back attitude keeps the actor sane,
and it doesn't hurt that it's totally in character.
"Superhero landing!
You know, that's really hard on your knees.Totally
impractical they all do it."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!